merci beaucoup l'udc alors sans plus
tarder je vais appeler pour la deuxième
table ronde nous intervenons madeleine
bazin de jessey dominique baude à pierre
andré périssol et nous rejoindra dans
quelques minutes
françois-xavier bellamy alors cette
table ronde nous avons parlé de
l'établissement nous allons parler dans
cette table ronde de l'enseignant
d'enseignants mieux formés mieux
reconnus qui est pour nous la clé de
voûte de la réussite des élèves alors
nous avons nous allons commencer par le
commencement quelque sorte par la
lecture par la maîtrise de la lecture
pour beaucoup d'entre nous c'est une
désolation de considérer que des élèves
puissent faire une grande partie de
lorsque l'arrêté sans maîtriser je
dirais le fondamental de tous les
fondamentaux qui est qui et la lecture
et en la matière nous aurons des
propositions précises à faire vous savez
je crois que le métier d'enseignant
c'est une c'est une mission comme le dit
souvent madame aquilina mais c'est aussi
une formation ce sont aussi des
techniques c'est un métier qu'il faut
apprendre et je crois qu'il faut aussi
considérer les choses de cette façon là
et de toutes les techniques
d'apprentissage celle qui consiste à
apprendre à apprendre à lire et
probablement l'une des plus fondamental
pour nous en parler
madeleine basane j'essaie qui est
elle-même enseignante c'est une
praticienne
elle est agrégée de lettres mais elle
est aussi secrétaire national au sein de
notre mouvement et je lui donne la
parole tout de suite
merci beaucoup a ni question
fondamentale donc l'apprentissage de la
lecture on peut même dire que c'est au
fond la clé de voûte de la réussite
scolaire d'un enfant et je suis
convaincu que nous aurons mot faire
toutes les réformes du collège que nous
voulons qu'elles soient bonnes ou
mauvaises elles seront parfaitement
vaine tant que certains ne
élèves continueront à arriver en sixième
sans savoir correctement lire et écrire
parce que pour eux c'est tragique mais
il est souvent trop tard
on n'apprend pas à courir un enfant qui
n'a pas correctement appris à marcher
alors certains me diront sans doute que
après tout un enfant qui n'est pas bon
en lecture en écriture pourra toujours
se raccrocher aux calculs mais on oublie
d'une part que le calcul est lui aussi
en chute libre aux primaires le niveau
ne cesse de baisser je n'ai
malheureusement pas le temps d'aborder
ce sujet là et surtout que pour qu'un
élève résolve correctement un problème
de physique de chimie de mathématiques
et bien il faut tout simplement qu'il
soit en mesure de lire et de comprendre
les noms c'est qu'il a sous les yeux
donc vous l'aurez compris cette question
c'est pour employer les termes adéquats
le b à ba de la réussite scolaire d'un
enfant est hélas les constats sont
particulièrement alarmants vous les
connaissez tous un enfant sur cinq sort
du cp sans savoir correctement lire et
écrire est en fait ces chiffres se
retrouve à l'entrée en sixième puisque
on retrouve là encore à peu près un
enfant sur cinq qui ne sait pas lire et
écrire et ou pas correctement et en tout
cas un enfant sur dix qui est carrément
en situation d'illettrisme donc le
cursus scolaire tout au long du primaire
loin de corriger ces difficultés ne fait
que les transvaser d'une classe à
l'autre
de telle sorte que l'élève accuse un
retard de plus en plus difficile à
combler alors face à ces constats qui a
eu tendance à faire l'éducation
nationale et bien elle a répondu sur
deux plans d'une part elle a largement
médicalisé le problème en diagnostiquant
comme dyslexiques les enfants qui
avaient de sérieuses difficultés à la
fin de l'année c'est à dire qu on
refourgue un peu le bébé à la sécurité
sociale
très pratique deuxième deuxième réponse
de l'éducation nationale ça a été de
casser le thermomètre
voilà de baisser considérablement
l'horizon d'exigence et dernier exemple
en date c'était ses consignes ces
directives données aux correcteurs de
copies du bac en juin dernier de ne pas
pénaliser les fautes d'orthographe qui
truffent aujourd'hui les copies de nos
élèves
alors lorsque l'on souhaite s'attaquer à
cette question de l'apprentissage de la
langue
très vite on en vient à la question
épineuse des méthodes de lecture et là
c'est un terrain miné parce que
particulièrement idéologisé avec cette
éternelle querelle entre méthode globale
méthodes syllabiques hélas idéologisé
puisque elle stérilise du coup le débat
est créée soit un peu les esprits dès
lors qu'on parle de méthodes
alors un bon moyen de désamorcer la
bombe en quelque sorte c'est d'une part
de des idéologies et le débat en
s'appuyant sur les travaux des sciences
et notamment des neurosciences et la
sociologie énormément de rapports que
soit celui du du neurologue stanislas de
haine de l'inserm en 2010 ou encore les
rapports de sociologues donc garcia et
holler jérôme d'aviau le rapport goigoux
pu récemment commandé par l'éducation
nationale
toutes ces enquêtes alors même qu'elles
proviennent de d'auteurs qui ont des
orientations politiques très diverse
aboutissent aux mêmes conclusions et
montre que pour savoir lire correctement
il faut deux actions simultanées il faut
d'abord des chiffres et un texte est
ensuite accéder au sens un bon lecteur
c'est celui qui se contente pas de lire
des phonèmes ou des mots mais qui
comprend le sens de ce qu'il y au moment
où il le lit or nos méthodes ont eu trop
souvent et des méthodes pédagogistes ont
eu tendance à supprimer l'étape
fondamentale du déchiffrage et bien il
est temps de réaffirmer son importance
pour donner toutes leurs chances à nos
élèves un moyen de des idéologies c'est
aussi ce débat c'est de souligner le
fait que les méthodes ne résoudrons pas
tous et que pour mettre en place des
méthodes qui marche et bien encore
faut-il évaluer les résultats obtenus au
long de l'année puis à la fin de l'année
il n'est pas question qu'un enfant entre
en cm1 sans savoir correctement lire et
écrire
c'est ce qui a été mis en place manière
très efficace en angleterre l'angleterre
qui est en train d' éradiquer
l'illettrisme
pourquoi parce qu'elle met en place des
tests de lecture tout à fait transparent
par établissement ce qui permet aux et
déjà aux parents de voir si
l'établissement a rempli son contrat et
aux établissements de rectifier un peu
leur méthode s'ils voient que celle-ci
n'obtient pas les résultats escomptés et
surtout cette évaluation on en parlait
de
on parlait de leur importance tout à
l'heure cette évaluation permet de
diagnostiquer les difficultés des élèves
et d'y remédier au plus tôt pour éviter
que les retards s'accumulent au fil du
temps un bon moyen aussi pardon de
mettre toutes les chances du côté de
l'élève
c'est des de l'enseigné les prérequis et
de la lecture dès la maternelle pour
qu'un élève parviennent à lire
correctement
eh bien ce sera d'autant plus facile
s'il connaît déjà les mots qu'il est en
train de lire or de ce point de vue là
la situation en france est
particulièrement inégalitaire puisqu'un
enfant en zep à trois fois moins de
vocabulaire qu'un enfant dans les autres
établissements et surtout cet
enseignement des prérequis la lecture en
maternelle permettrait de voir quels
enfants ont déjà quelques difficultés
pour pouvoir mettre les bouchées doubles
ensuite pour ces élèves en cp on
soulignera aussi le rôle fondamental de
l'enseignant et sereine intéressant par
exemple de donner une formation
spécifique aux enseignants qui
souhaitent se consacrer aux classes de
cp pour qu'ils deviennent de vrais
spécialistes de la lecture
et enfin il faut bien comprendre que
cette question de la maîtrise de la
langue mériterait d'être érigée en
grande cause nationale et d'impliquer
les acteurs bien au delà de l'école
d'impliquer des collectivités les
médiathèques d'impliquer bien sûr les
parents qui sont les premiers éducateurs
de leurs enfants de les inciter à faire
lire leurs enfants à faire aimer la
lecture à leurs enfants
et puis on pourrait imaginer d'impliquer
aussi les jeunes en service civique ou
les seniors à la retraite qui viendrait
faire lire ces jeunes enfants je
terminerai par là il faut bien
comprendre que la maîtrise de la lecture
engagent notre avenir à tous ce qu'un
enfant ne parviendra pas à dire avec des
mots à exprimer par écrit avec des mots
il sera tenté de l'exprimer par le point
par la violence un enfant à qui la
lecture est pénible et rébarbative
c'est un enfant qui plus tard ne lira
pas hélas un enfant qui ne forcera pas
au fil de ses lectures son sens critique
son esprit critique et son libre arbitre
et donc un enfant qui se donnera
d'autant plus vulnérables face aux
manipulations en tout genre et notamment
les manipulations conspiration
nice complotistes et sectaires sur
internet qui ont une actu une actualité
brûlante
hélas donc voilà quelle doit être notre
ambition notre ambition brûlante ardente
pour nos enfants tout simplement leur
transmettre leur droit le plus
fondamental dont ils sont spoliés hausse
aujourd'hui celui d'avoir accès à la
mémoire à la culture de leur pays et de
leur père ce qui leur permettra plus
tard d'agir de penser et de se conduire
en homme est enfin libre merci merci
madeleine pour ce plaidoyer vibrant et
est tout à fait convaincant nous sommes
absolument sur la même longueur d'onde
tous autant que nous sommes ici
rassemblées et nous avons des
propositions précises aux républicains
en la matière d'abord nous voulons qu'il
y ait dans la formation des enseignants
une certification apprentissage de la
lecture une certification apprentissage
des mathématiques parce que madeleine
l'a dit très rapidement mais un élève
sur cinq ans 3e ne sait pas résoudre un
problème de cm2 donc on a aussi un gros
problème dans la maîtrise des
mathématiques
alors que la france est un grand pays de
tradition mathématiques deuxièmement
nous voulons qu'il y ait un référent
lecture par établissement et nous
voulons enfin que les meilleurs
enseignants soient dévolus au cp l'année
de l'apprentissage de la lecture
un mot sur le redoublement vous veillez
en préparant nous nos travaux on a
diabolisé complètement le redoublement
redoublement est diabolique en france on
ne double pas j'ai interrogé une jeune
enseignante de ce1 et je lui ai dit que
je connais je lui ai dit tu as des
élèves est-ce que lorsqu'ils arrivent
chez toi sans savoir lire
il récupère la maîtrise de la lecture et
la réponse qu'elle m'a fait est la
suivante et je crois qu'il faut qu'on
écoute les praticiens de terrain
elle m'a dit non il ne rattrape pas pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce qu'on
sait 20 on ne refait pas le processus
d'apprentissage de la lecture
excusez moi et deuxièmement parce que le
cea est une année très lourde en termes
de programme on apprend la grammaire la
conjugaison les temps si l'élève ne sait
pas lire il est perdu il a débordé donc
que cet exemple de terrain nous aspire
dans nos réflexions sur nos stratégies
alors nous allons à présent écouter
dominique baude à professeur des
universités en sociologie lsp de créteil
dont il est le vice le directeur adjoint
et puis cette cette direction qu'il
assume coiffe également la
responsabilité de l'ensemble des
formations de la solidarité ainsi que la
mise en oeuvre d'une démarche qualité
donc dominique bona nous l'avons compris
va nous parler de formation des
enseignants qui est un point capital un
bon enseignant certains enseignants bien
formés
monsieur bona à vous la parole merci
madame la députée une petite
rectification je ne suis pas responsable
de la solidarité mais de la scolarité
mais bon quelque part il ya une forme
qui est quelquefois quelque part une
forme de solidarité dedans alors écoutez
comme point de départ puisque la
commande était celle ci je vais vous
parler plus spécifiquement du concours
de recrutement des profs des écoles
alors c'est un petit peu important parce
que deux constats d'abord si je regarde
les études pisa pisanu dit que
finalement l'école française n'est ni
l'école des meilleurs ni l'école des
moins bons et je ne suis pas bien sûr
qu'aujourd'hui ce soit à l'école des
moyens donc l'école de la république
n'est pas en train de de répondre aux
attentes que l'on a en elle
deuxième constat celui qui dit li à deux
ans dans l'académie de versailles où
nous avons recruté au niveau du concours
de professeurs des écoles des gens qui
n'avaient pas atteint 6 de moyenne
générale à l'issue des épreuves du
concours cette année au sein de
l'académie de créteil nous sommes nous
avons recruté à peu près à 8 et nous
avons été obligés d'opérer deux
recrutements c'est à dire ce qu'on a
appelé un concours supplémentaires alors
sa pause
ce problème puisque luc chatel nous
invitait à considérer que l'école
primaire était le lieu où tout se passe
et ce que je crois réellement à la suite
de la conférencière qui m'a précédé
ici je crois qu'effectivement il faut se
poser la question du recrutement
et puis du niveau d'exigence que l'on
peut avoir que l'on doit avoir au niveau
des concours d'entrée alors ça pose
simplement une question qui est qui
voulons-nous recruter et qui ne voulons
nous pas recruter parce que finalement
ce recrutement
c'est quelque part une question
sélection alors pour ceux qui ne le
sauraient pas finalement le recrutement
se fait en deux temps
premier temps les espèces les écoles
supérieures du professeur et l'éducation
depuis qu'elles sont en charge de la
formation des enseignants par le biais
de l'âme de la masterisation détecte un
certain nombre de candidats sélectionne
un certain nombre de candidats qui elle
va former par le biais des composantes
c'est-à-dire mathématiques littérature
histoire tout ce que vous voulez va
former les gens pour préparer le
concours
ce concours aura lieu grosso modo pour
faire simple et mais en même temps un
petit peu large
entre janvier et avril autrement dit en
l'espace de quatre mois
les gens devront être formés devront
suivre des stages sur le terrain
réussir le concours et deviendront
quelque part enseignants puisque au
moment où ils vont intégrer la deuxième
année de master ici on va les envoyer en
stage ils continueront leur formation
ils réussiront parleurs leur stage ils
feront à mémoire et à la fin on va
valider leur stage la directrice de
l'espé chez moi madame marin va valider
également et donner un avis et le tout
donnera une titularisation
autrement dit aujourd'hui dans le
processus de masterisation
attention ne me faites pas dire ce que
je n'ai pas dit je suis pour le
processus de masterisation mettant le
processus de masterisation tel qu'il est
pensé aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas en
capacité de former correctement des
enseignants pour le futur ne sera pas en
mesure de former les enseignants sur
pour le futur parce que premièrement ils
ne font pas assez de terrains pas assez
de stage
deuxièmement nous avons un faible bassin
de recrutement
donc nous ne sommes pas en mesure de
détecter réellement des gens de haut
niveau troisièmement nous sommes dans
une société de crise ça veut dire quoi
une société de crise est bien
l'enseignement devient aujourd'hui un
emploi refuge qui permet à des gens de
travailler entre de vacances et il n'ya
pas d'apriori sur ce que je viens de
dire mais de travailler entre deux
vacances pour un salaire somme toute
dérisoire je vous rappelle qu'un
professeur des écoles commencent à 1700
euros brut par mois
donc si nous voulons à un moment donné
recruter des enseignants de qualité
il va falloir revoir le cycle de
formation permettre d'avoir des stages
beaucoup plus long attirer les gens avec
une rémunération qui est beaucoup plus
importante
mettre des contraintes sur la
titularisation des contraintes sur la
titularisation parce qu'on ne peut pas
être titularisé simplement sur quatre
mois de stage
et puis la vie d'un directeur ou une
directrice d'espèces qui ne connaît même
pas les étudiants pour lequel elle signe
ou il signe la vie c'est impossible
donc il faut allonger cette cette
procédure il faut mettre le chef
d'établissement dans la boucle pour
pouvoir réellement titulariser avoir un
avis il faut avoir un enseignant
référent qui lui aussi va mettre un avis
il faut peut-être retarder la
titularisation et non pas le faire au
bout d'un an pour le faire au bout de
trois ans bae a sorti ses trois années
de formation continue tout autant tout
au long des trois années de manière
finalement excusez moi l'expression
elle n'est peut-être pas très belle mais
à la partie à la bible de manière à
séparer le bon grain de l'ivraie
vous savez il faut savoir parfois laissé
tous ses livres et pour ne pas se
séparer du bon grain et si on le fait
trop tôt ça nous pose quelques problèmes
alors au moment où je vous dis ça
finalement
voyez bien que c'est tout un processus
qui est à repenser tout à l'heure il ya
une table ronde sur les universités bien
évidemment ça pose la question des
étudiants que nous avons à l'université
parce que si nous avons aujourd'hui un
système éducatif qui forment le mot mal
ses élèves qui deviennent des étudiants
et des étudiants pas forcément de très
haut niveau
j'aurais tendance à dire il n'y a pas
simplement que les élèves qui ne savent
pas lire nier
rires beaucoup de nos étudiants des
universités ne savent ni lire ni écrire
et dans le monde
autre qui est le mien je ne sais même
pas s'ils savent et pelé pour la plupart
alors là dedans on a un vrai problème de
détection et on doit quelque part mettre
des barrières qui permette réellement de
travailler sans prendre davantage de
temps parce que nous avons que cinq ou
six minutes ça pose la question de
l'organisation des sp aujourd'hui qui
est aujourd'hui complètement à revoir
puisque les sp les écoles supérieures du
professeur et d'éducation le système est
bon sur le principe c'est le
fonctionnement général qui est mauvais
puisque les espèces sur la première
année ne gère absolument pas les
formations qui sont gérés à l'intérieur
des composantes comme je vous l'aï dit
tout à l'heure si on ne donne pas les
moyens aux écoles supérieures du
professorat d'éducation de gérer dès la
première année réellement les
enseignements et les contenus si on ne
force pas sur les stages et bien nous
aurons des enseignants de mauvaise
qualité et mal formés merci merci
beaucoup monsieur godard donc nous
retenons plusieurs choses importantes de
votre propos c'est la première chose
c'est que on doit avoir une exigence
particulière sur la qualité et la
formation de nos enseignants au fond ce
dont nous allons parler avec monsieur
périssol le socle le socle de
connaissances et compétences que le
maître est censé exigé de l'élève
eh bien il faut que l'institution
l'exigent du professeur lui-même qu'il
sache maîtriser les savoirs qu'il est
supposé enseigner ce n'est qu'à cette
condition là qu'il peut former
convenablement et sans doute les
socialistes ont créé les sp les écoles
supérieures du professeur à et de
l'éducation en remplacement des iufm les
iufm ne marchait pas les sp aujourd'hui
ne donne pas satisfaction il faudra donc
y revenir
vous avez dit deux choses importantes
l'importance de la formation initiale
qui est délivré par l'université dont
c'est le rôle pour autant qu'on lui
passe commande de ce que nous voulons et
puis bien sûr la formation pratique
c'est une des propositions que nous
ferons
il faut et je reprends le
que j'avais aimé de marcel gauchet il
faut un cahier des charges précis pour
le métier d'enseignant
c'est une proposition que nous voulons
reprendre il faut un seuil
incompressible de savoir exigible des
élèves professeurs il faut des
certifications complémentaires
il faut aussi diversifier les parcours
savez vous que 80 % des étudiants
professeurs ont une formation littéraire
ça nous réjouir à nous sommes des
littéraires un certain nombre notamment
françois xavier bellamy qui vient
d'arriver et que je salue
mais il faut aussi des scientifiques on
a besoin d'avoir des professeurs des
professeurs qui sont qu'ils soient de
bons scientifiques également donc la
formation quelque chose de tout à fait
essentiel et on compte sur et bien des
dirigeants des specs comme vous monsieur
gaudin pour faire avancer cette question
tout à fait fondamental alors je vais
donner la parole à présent à pierre
andré périssol polytechnicien de
formation personne n'est parfait
en effet les énarques le dirait de la
même façon que vous n'aurez très
admiratif de cette belle et grande
formation que d'ailleurs les socialistes
cherchent à abîmer aussi n'est ce pas
mais c'est un autre sujet vous avez été
ministre en charge du logement dans le
gouvernement d'alain juppé vous êtes
maire de moulins depuis 1995 vous avez
eu le bonheur de mettre en place la
réforme des rythmes scolaires comme tous
les maires de france et vous présidez
vous avez présider une mission
d'information parlementaire sur la
définition des savoirs enseignés et sur
la personnalisation du parcours
alors monsieur périssol vous allez nous
parler j'imagine de socle de savoir ça
fait discuter encore aujourd'hui moi je
on a beaucoup discuté au moment de la
loi de refondation de l'école sur le le
socle de compétences de connaissances et
de culture et
et ça pose la question de
l'éparpillement et de la priorisation
aussi est-ce qu'il faut initier les
élèves a tous demandé aux enseignants
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils pensent du
développement durable ils en sont gavés
10 le développement durable c'est
important mais on n'en peut plus on ne
finit par croire que tout est
développement durable que c'est l'alpha
et l'oméga l'éducation donc monsieur
périssol sur ces savoirs qu'avez vous à
nous dire merci
comme je suis je me considère vraiment
comme un pur produit de l'école de la
république je cherche à savoir comment
je peux rendre un petit peu à l'école
tout ce qu'elle m'a apporté
et c'est vrai a évoqué ce qu'on a fait
pour moi dans une vie antérieure
notamment dans cette mission sur le
socle commun où j'ai été beaucoup aidé
par un frédéric par une députée aussi de
besançon qui m'a beaucoup aidé et donc
je veux vraiment tous vous remercier
alors j'ai tout à l'heure combien vous
étiez frappé par le fait que la plupart
de nos concitoyens mettre vraiment
l'école au premier rang de leurs
préoccupations
et c'est vrai que le débat est très
largement partagé malheureusement je
pense que nos concitoyens et la nation
général a du mal à s'approprier le
départ et je pense que c'est vraiment un
enjeu majeur vous évoquiez au début avec
luc chatel la double mission de l'école
de la république qui consiste d'abord à
transmettre à 100% 100% de ses élèves un
socle fondamentaux fait de connaissances
et de compétences et de comportement
aussi un socle limité mais partagée par
tous et puis la deuxième mission qui
consiste à amener chacun le plus loin
plus loin où il peut aller avec ses
talents et ses capacités
or l'école on l'a dit ne remplit aucune
de ses missions un quart un cinquième
des enfants ne maîtrise pas les
fondamentaux le lire écrire compter
et la gauche a beau essayer de casser le
thermomètre vous l'avez dit
malheureusement
on a toujours à peu près un quart de nos
enfants qui sont au bord de la route
et deuxièmement l'école de la république
échoué aujourd'hui à créer le litre dont
le pays a besoin puisque on le voit à
chaque évaluations pisa notre pays
régresse et donc on a ce double échec
qui n'est pas pour moi un échec
inéluctable pour que l'école puisse
remplir ces deux missions il faut à mon
sens réunir au moins trois conditions
d'autres aussi les trois conditions au
coeur du réacteur le premier c'est
effectivement vous avez très bien dit
réglages mais très courageusement il
faut instituer un socle commun qui par
définition doit être réduit par rapport
au programme
sinon c'est plus un socle fondamental
commun et donc il faut définir ce qui
est fondamental c'est à dire ceux sans
quoi on ne peut pas aller plus loin il
faut définir ce socle pour tous à tous
les niveaux aux différents cycles et
définir ce soft qui dans la maîtrise
doit être évaluée et doit conditionner
le passage plus loin voir l'orientation
et au delà ce socle là des programmes
mais c'est encore une fois au delà et ça
doit permettre à chacun d'aller plus
loin
deuxième enjeu c'est l'enjeu de la
personnalisation
face à l'échec la gauche ne pense qu'en
termes quantitatifs un problème il faut
plus enseignants il ya eu plus
d'enseignants on n'a pas progressé en a
même régressé donc ce n'est pas la
solution
c'est évident et donc ce qui me semble
assez indispensable c'est la
personnalisation de l'enseignement du
châtel le rappelait est de faire en
sorte qu' on ne maudit l'arize
l'enseignement c'est à dire que je ne
passe à un autre module je ne passe à la
6e à la suite que lorsque j'ai acquis ce
qui est fondamental d'ailleurs parce que
si je n'ai les pâquis jeune âge ne le
rattrapera jamais mais surtout je
pourrais pas acquérir la suite si quand
on veut faire avancer tout le monde au
même rythme pour aller au même endroit
eh bien on condamne à l'échec
tous ceux qui ne peuvent pas suivre à
peu près
un tiers pas pardon un cinquième cas et
deuxièmement prive la nation d'une élite
républicaine en bridant ce qui aurait
elle pu aller plus loin ou plus vite
il faut donc développer les voies de
personnalisation en enseignant par
module ou par groupes de compétences et
enfin ça a été évidemment souhaité dès
lors qu'on fait confiance aux
enseignants aux chefs d'établissement ça
veut dire qu'on donne une certaine
autonomie à ces établissements et b à ce
moment là il faut bien contractualiser
évaluer et tirer les conséquences
lorsque ça marche et lorsque ça ne
marche pas pour réaliser et concrétiser
se tripotent socle fondamental commun
personnalisation contractualisation
généré pas là il faut de la
détermination parce que pour définir en
commun
il faut faire des choix il faut avoir le
courage de dire non un certain nombre de
choses
faute de quoi on remplit complètement la
barque et elle n'est plus un socle
fondamental commun et deuxièmement il
faut combattre l'idéologie de la gauche
qui dit que avec ça on va créer une
élite et ce faisant on l'a dit elle
plombe
elle condamne à l'élève sur sur cinq
coups sûrs quatre échecs et deuxièmement
elle prive la nation d'avoir une élite
formée par l'école de la république
si elle n'est pas fort mais pas les
colères épiques est formée par tous et
formés par les parents par les classes
sociales et donc on condamnant l' école
pour former une élite républicaine elle
condamne à ce qu'il y ait une élite sur
des critères sociaux ou financier et je
voudrais vous donner la conséquence de
sa passe je suis pas sûr qu on l'est
tous en tête aller voir la définition du
socle tel que l'a fait la gauche dans
2015 et vous verrez le socle vu par la
gauche
n'est pas une base je dirais que c'est
même pas sommet c'est un idéal qui est
inatteignable
je n'ai pas et évaluer mon propre sauf
que lorsque j'avais 15 ans à la sortie
mais j'aurais été incapable de répondre
on a tout mis tout et même plus que tout
est donc à bonal joué à mon niveau
licence m'avait dit un grand spécialiste
de ces questions
absolument c'est à dire qu'elle a tué le
socle est donc ce faisant on a plombé
tout un ensemble de notre dispositif
alors il faut avoir le courage de main y
a pas que des mots il faut avoir le
courage un de définir un socle et je
souhaite je le redis je n'avais pas été
suivies pop qu'ils soient validées par
la représentation nationale parce que
qu'est-ce que c'est le socle c'est ce
que la nation confie à l'école de
transmettre à 100 % de ces jeunes et on
l'a eu à différentes époques de notre
histoire regardait le soc défini par
condorcet regardez le socle est défini à
la fin du dix neuvième siècle
il faut que la nation prenne ses
responsabilités et bien voilà ce que je
considère comme essentielles
deuxièmement il faut avoir le courage de
personnaliser l'enseignement c'est déjà
d'avoir résisté par module troisièmement
de contractualiser et de faire confiance
aux établissements il ya d'autres
conditions
mais je crois qu'on est là au coeur du
réacteur de l'école et je pense que
c'est une magnifique mission pour les
républicains de porter ce message et
ainsi de préserver l'avenir de nos
jeunes donc l'avenir de notre pays merci
merci monsieur le ministre
alors je ne vous cache pas que l'idée de
confier à la représentation nationale le
soin de définir les programmes ne fait
pas l'unanimité parce que ce qu'une
majorité politique peut faire une autre
majorité politique peut le défaire et je
crois que précisément il faut essayer d
idéologie c'est l'école
les socialistes ont beaucoup trop
idéologisé et nous devons être vigilants
en tout état de cause il se veut il se
fait aujourd'hui un consensus autour de
l'idée que il y à des savoirs qui sont
plus fondamentaux que d'autres nous
avons parlé de la langue
français la langue de la république est
le français alain finkielkraut a eu ce
mot terrible il y à peu en disant les
français deviennent étrangers à leur
propre langue
il faut renouer avec notre langue sa
grammaire son orthographe ses auteurs il
faut effectivement prioriser
l'apprentissage de la langue
l'apprentissage des mathématiques parce
que c'est essentiel pour la formation
d'un jeune et puis j'ajouterai celle de
l'histoire aussi parce que l'histoire ça
emporte avec elle
énormément de choses mais je ne voudrais
pas empiéter sur le propos à venir de
notre dernier intervenant du cette table
ronde
françois-xavier bellamy que beaucoup
d'entre vous connaissent parce qu'il a
une présence médiatique absolument
formidable il est très présent dans les
médias et nous en sommes ravis
françois-xavier bellamy outre sa
fonction de maire adjoint à versailles
en charge de l'emploi de la genèse
l'enseignement secondaire et de
l'enseignement supérieur et surtout
professeur agrégé de philosophie et il a
publié en 2014 année c'est dont je vous
recommande chaudement la lecture
intitulée les déshérités où l'urgence de
transmettre qui traite de la crise de la
culture
cher françois xavier merci pour votre
présence je vous laisse la parole merci
infiniment pour votre invitation
pardonnez moi de rejoindre en cours de
route de vos travaux j'espère que mon
propos ne sera pas redondant je crois
que l'état de l'école a été suffisamment
documenté par les interventions
précédentes et que nous connaissons tous
la crise que notre système scolaire
traverse
il est probablement inutile d'y revenir
mais je crois que nous ne parviendrons
pas à répondre à cette crise si nous ne
pensons pas d'abord la réalité de cette
crise comme étant la nôtre ce n'est pas
d'abord la crise de notre école ce n'est
pas d'abord l'échec de nos enseignants
c'est d'abord notre échec à tous c'est
l'échec de la société dans son ensemble
et avant même de parler d'ailleurs de ce
que la société peut attendre de l'école
il faut d'abord commencer par constater
que la société est responsable de son
école et par compte
quand responsables de l'état de son
école il y a évidemment des propositions
politiques à proposer à fixer à
développer il y à des réformes de
structure à faire il y à des méthodes a
changé mais avant tout je crois que ce
qui est en jeu dans la crise de l'école
c'est d'abord la crise du sens même de
l'école de la signification de l'école
d'une signification que me semble-t-il
nous avons collectivement perdu de vue
droite et gauche confondues d'ailleurs
et il me paraîtrait spécialement mal
venue dans la situation actuelle de
faire de la gauche l'unique responsable
de la crise de l'école parce que c'est
encore une fois de notre échec collectif
qu'il s'agit pour une raison très simple
et qui tient tout entière à cette
ambiguïté à cette erreur me semble-t-il
qui est contenu même dans le concept
même du socle actuel qui s'appelle vous
l'avez rappelé socle commun de
connaissances de compétences et de
culture nous avons passé notre temps à
demander à l'école de transmettre une
pluralité de choses ou plus exactement
de développer chez l'enfant une
pluralité de dimension et nous avons
pensé qu'il était nécessaire de
transmettre non pas seulement des
connaissances mais des compétences non
pas seulement de la culture et des
savoirs mais des savoir faire et des
savoir être
nous avons déplacé le centre de gravité
de l'école jusqu'à finalement faire
penser que la connaissance et la culture
pouvait passer au second plan et c'est
là ce que la gauche et c'est vrai en
train d'accomplir d'une manière
absolument dramatique avec la réforme du
collège qui va contribuer encore à cette
incroyable dispersion au lieu de la
maîtrise de la langue française
c'est désormais la maîtrise des langages
dont il est question avec
l'apprentissage du code informatique des
lanceurs au lieu de la maîtrise de la
culture fondamentale c'est d'un certain
nombre de compétences que nous devons
nous faire les garants avec l'idée qu'au
fond le principal rôle de l'école c'est
de préparer demain des salariés
opérationnel dans la vie en entreprise
c'est tout le principe des enseignements
pratiques interdisciplinaire par exemple
qui veulent défaire les disciplines
perçus comme des facteurs anxiogènes
angoissant des facteurs d'inhibition
pour les élèves casser les disciplines
pour mettre les élèves en activité et
remplacer ainsi les connaissances par
les compétences et bien c'est cette
grande erreur c'est cette énorme erreur
qui est au coeur me semble-t-il de la
crise de l'école parce qu'elle est au
fond fondée sur cet oubli décisif un
oubli qui fait que nous avons perdu le
sens de la valeur
de la culture le sens de la valeur de la
connaissance et là encore je crois
n'ayons pas peur de le reconnaître
la droite et la gauche sont associés
dans ce même oubli combien de fois à
droite avons nous entendu que l'école
avait pour but de préparer des salariés
pour demain que l'école ne devait plus
se disperser dans des connaissances un
peu gratuites mais qu'elle devait au
contraire se recentrer sur l'utilité sur
l'efficacité sur le pragmatisme comme si
précisément dans sa gratuité la culture
n'était pas le préalable indispensable à
la formation de personnalités qui soit
vraiment accompli et qui donc soit aussi
vraiment efficace y compris dans le
monde professionnel et dans le monde
citoyens de fait dans les déshérités
j'ai essayé de développer une intuition
toute simple et c'est la seule antichan
que je voudrais tenter de de rappeler ce
matin c'est que on ne devient jamais soi
même sans la culture que l'on reçoit
sans la langue que l'on reçoit la langue
ça n'est pas simplement la langue de la
république la langue c'est aussi la
langue de chaque citoyen c'est même la
langue de chaque être humain et c'est
toujours par la langue que l'on
accomplit sa propre liberté dans la
pensée rendez vous compte de cette chose
aberrante qu'avant la réforme de la
massification du collège avant le
collège unique un élève de collège en
france avait six heures de français par
semaine et 9 heures pour un professeur
se dire six heures dans trois heures
dédoublées
actuellement il à 5h30 de français et
avec la réforme actuelle du collège
eh bien il pourra n'en avoir que deux
heures trente par semaine d'enseignement
de français parce que nous avons pensé
qu'il était préférable plutôt que
d'enseigner le français est d'enseigner
des textes de france est de pouvoir
mettre nos élèves en activité dans des
enseignements pratiques où ils vont
désormais devoir rédiger des publicités
pour des parfums ou des légumes
quelle énorme aberration de penser que
nous pouvons être créatif sans avoir
d'abord reçu quelle énorme aberration ça
a été et est encore une fois je crois
que la droite et la gauche ont entretenu
cette illusion
quelle énorme aberration ça a été de
faire penser qu'au fond avec le
numérique avec internet avec les
nouveaux moyens de la connaissance et du
savoir nous allions finalement pouvoir
nous passer des enseignants nous passer
de la médiation des enseignants nous
passer de cet intermédiaire décisive qui
le constituent oui bien sûr l'école a
pour but de transmettre la connaissance
et la culture et la connaissance et la
culture peuvent paraître gratuit dans
leur don initial dans leurs
transmissions fondamentale mais c'est
cette gratuité qui font de la liberté
des élèves
alors si j'avais une seule proposition à
faire ce serait celle d'une certaine
façon d'accepter de faire vraiment
confiance à l'école et de faire vraiment
à nouveau confiance aux enseignants en
les laissant faire leur mission
fondamentale elle n'est pas très
compliqué cette mission et finalement la
réforme de l'école n'est pas si
compliqué que cela elle pourrait
consister à dire contrairement à ce que
la gauche fait depuis quatre ans qu'au
fond la mission fondamentale de l'école
c'est de transmettre des connaissances
et que tout le reste vient en surplus au
début du dernier quinquennat
vincent peillon a écrit une lettre aux
enseignants qui résumait les missions de
l'école et dans cette lettre de quatre
pages l'école avait dit cette mission il
fallait lutter contre le racisme lutter
contre les stéréotypes sexistes lutter
contre les inégalités économiques lutter
contre les discriminations sociales
lutter même contre le réchauffement
climatique et c'était la grande cause
2015 de l'école avant que les attentats
de charlie hebdo ne vienne un peu
modifier l'ordre des priorités en 2015
l'école avait pour mission de lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique en
transformant la conscience éco citoyenne
de ses élèves
de fait en même temps qu'on lui propose
cette diversité de missions on la prive
du moyen par lequel elle pourrait y
parvenir
l'école peuvent faire tout cela elle
peut contribuer à préparer des meilleurs
citoyens pour demain elle peut
contribuer à préparer des bons
professionnels pour les entreprises qui
viendront elle peut contribuer à
préparer aussi tout simplement des êtres
humains libres responsables respectueux
de leur environnement
mais elle ne peut y parvenir que par un
seul moyen tout simple c'est la
transmission de la culture et c'est tout
et si on acceptait de faire à nouveau
confiance aux enseignants en leur disant
que le savoir qu'ils ont à faire
partager par tous les moyens que leur
bon sens pédagogique pourra leur
permettre de développer par tous les
moyens que leur formation enfin
restaurée et refondée sur des principes
simples pourra leur permettre d'acquérir
alors si on pouvait leur dire à nouveau
que ce savoir est la clé de la liberté
de leurs élèves que ce savoir qu'ils
peuvent faire partager et le chemin pour
que leurs élèves accèdent à la plénitude
de leur personnalité de leur
accomplissement personnel
alors nous aurions dépassé déjà toutes
les difficultés qui sont aujourd'hui au
coeur de la crise de l'école
contemporaine et encore une fois je
crois que nous en sommes collectivement
responsables il serait vain de penser
que c'est un petit groupe de personnes
qui dans les cercles idéologique de la
gauche a pris en otage l'éducation
nationale et que ce petit groupe de
personnes auraient détourné l'école à
des fins partisanes
je crois que ça n'est pas
fondamentalement le cas ce qui est en
jeu ce n'est pas la méchanceté supposé
de quelques uns c'est la générosité mal
fondé du plus grand nombre
nous avons cru trop longtemps que nos
élèves pouvaient se passer
d'enseignement parce qu'ils avaient
internet que nous élève pouvait se
passer de professeurs si on leur donnait
des tablettes nous avons cru trop
longtemps que nos élèves pouvaient se
passer de recevoir des connaissances et
qu'il fallait les mettre en activité
d'une façon immédiate et spontanée or la
liberté n'est pas spontané la liberté
n'est pas immédiate la liberté suppose
ce chemin qu'est le savoir et la
connaissance la connaissance
fondamentale et c'est cela qui donne un
sens à ce qu'on appelle le socle le
socle ne peut avoir de signification
réelle que si on retrouve le sens
essentiel la valeur essentielle de la
culture
la droite l'a oubliée trop longtemps il
ne faut pas avoir peur de le reconnaître
non pas pour tenter de distribuer les
responsabilités mais au contraire pour
refonder notre propre action éducative
et je terminerai en disant simplement
que je crois que nous sommes devant un
rendez vous historique pour deux raisons
la première raison c'est que c'est vrai
beaucoup d'enseignants ont cru pendant
très longtemps que l'alternance à gauche
allait leur redonner une place à
l'intérieur de la société beaucoup
d'enseignants vivent très
douloureusement la crise contemporaine
de l'école parce qu'on les charges d'une
responsabilité alors que je crois cette
responsabilité elle est au moins
partager et beaucoup d'enseignants ont
cru que la gauche allait leur refaire
confiance leur redonner cette
responsabilité à laquelle il aspire tant
est bien le moins qu'on pût qu'on puisse
dire c'est qu'ils ont été profondément
déçu et c'est la raison pour laquelle en
2017 nous avons peut-être en tous les
cas la famille politique de la droite et
du centre a sans doute une chance
décisif de tendre à nouveau la main aux
enseignants en acceptant de leur faire à
nouveau confiance et de comprendre à
nouveau le sens même le sens profond de
leur métier il y a en tous les cas me
semble-t-il un rendez vous décisif qui
se joue en 2017 pour l'école de la
république et toutes les familles
politiques sont concernés bien sûr mais
plus particulièrement celle qui a la
charge de préparer une authentique
alternance c'est la première raison de
ce rendez-vous historique et puis la
deuxième raison c'est que vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure derrière la question du
niveau des élèves la question du niveau
des enseignants de leur niveau de
culture et de connaissance à eux
et bien c'est très clair que nous sommes
là aussi devant un rendez vous
historique parce qu'une société peut
faire des mauvais choix dans l'histoire
elle peut se tromper et corriger ces
erreurs
c'est vrai dans beaucoup de lieux de
notre vie collective ça n'est pas vrai
pour l'école quand on a pendant très
longtemps rompu avec la transmission du
savoir
alors le savoir se perd la culture n'est
pas un capital comme le disait bourdieu
la culture n'est pas un bagage on peut
pas la laisser de côté quand on n'a
cessé de transmettre la culture la
culture ce père elle disparaît où irons
nous demain recruter les enseignants
parmi les élèves qui n'auront pas reçu
ce que nous n'avons pas su transmettre
quand demain à partir de la rentrée
prochaine en septembre plus aucun élève
de collège n'apprendra le latin et le
grec qui demain formera les professeurs
de latin et de grec quand nous aurons
retrouvé le sens de la valeur
essentielle de ce trésor culturel que
nous auront cessé de transmettre
nous sommes là devant un rendez vous
historique si les enseignants
d'aujourd'hui sont moins bons que ceux
d'hier
et de fait je m'inclus dedans je n'ai
pas reçu la même éducation que mes
parents je n'ai pas eu la même école que
mes parents et mon mais mais mais mes
connaissances mon socle de culture est
bien inférieur à celui que d'autres
avaient pu avoir avant moi bien ce n'est
pas tant de notre faute c'est d'une
certaine façon la responsabilité
collective de 2 de l'école et c'est la
responsabilité collective de la société
mais de fait il faut que nous soyons
très vigilants parce que la culture que
nous cessons de transmettre elle ne se
refonde pas tout seul et par conséquent
nous sommes à un rendez vous historique
si nous ne savons pas reconstruire
l'école aujourd'hui alors quelque chose
sera perdu de façon irréversible
nous n'avons aucune raison de désespérer
il y a vraiment une chance historique
d'agir en 2017 il y a vraiment un rendez
vous décisif mais il faut être présent à
ce rendez vous sinon il sera trop tard
merci merci vous venez de d'exprimer
magnifiquement ce qui est notre
conviction profonde alors si nous avions
eu un peu plus de temps j'aurais voulu
vous passez un petit film mais je
demanderai aux organisateurs des
républicains de le mettre sur le site un
petit film qu'a réalisé robert de l'or
qui devait être des nôtres ce matin qui
a été empêchée qui est professeur de
lettres classiques et qui est président
de l'association
arrête ton char qui fait un travail
absolument extraordinaire pour lutter
contre la disparition du de
l'enseignement du latin et du grec à la
faveur
de la réforme du collège j'étais avec
legendary ton char la semaine dernière
au festival de latin et de grec à lyon
et nous avons avec les élèves déclamer
du ceran sur la place des terreaux
c'était tout à fait sympathique mais
enfin au delà du caractère sympathique
de l'initiative ya un danger absolument
majeur et cher françois xavier j'avais
utilisé exactement les mêmes mots que
vous lorsque l'annoncé avait été faite
de la disparition en l'état de
l'enseignement du latin et du grec parce
que ne nous y trompons pas le latin pour
tous de madame najat vallaud-belkacem
c'est le latin pour personne on étudie
plus la langue on étudie un vernis de
culture antique ce n'est pas du tout la
même chose l'étude résonnait de la
langue et j'avais dit à la ministre vous
savez une langue qu'on n'apprend plus
c'est une langue qu'on n'apprend plus à
enseigner et vous avez raison de dire
qu'une un capital culturel une culture
que se perdent une civilisation peut
mourir
l'histoire nous en a fourni l'exemple
hélas donc je crois qu'il y à là
vraiment quelque chose de tout à fait
dangereux et qui en plus est socialement
à contre courant de ce que la gauche
prétend vouloir faire je m'explique le
latin est la première des options
enseigné dans les collèges en zone
d'éducation prioritaire
toutes les études attestent qu'un élève
qui a fait du latin réussit mieux dans
les autres disciplines
donc il y a là un contresens tragique et
je vous le dis tout net une des
propositions phare des républicains sera
l'abrogation pure et simple de la
réforme du collège
voilà j'en termine sur cette table ronde
en vous remerciant madame messieurs pour
à votre contribution